The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt mod tools' have
made their way to PC as someone walking
into modding with fairly basic knowledge
of the tools used my experience and
changing the textures of broach have
been wonderful even you can make quick
one-off textures here we have how's my
writing a texture that truly removes the
shame and running into people and for
the very first time in Witcher you can
experience VR with the Palmer Luckey or
how about the my little
No Roach is not some kind of show-off
walking billboard he's better than that
all jokes aside once you get the hang of
uncooked and packing the game files back
and forth and if you put a fair amount
of time into a texture you can make some
pretty cool stuff
for instance this skeleton horse took me
a couple of hours and by the third try I
had something to show off eat your heart
out Wild Hunt clearly it isn't perfect
but for the most part not too shabby
again this only took me a couple of
hours and I'm sure you guys can do
better so sack up and get in there and
make something amazing change your life
today you can do it
I know you can you can do it